[Applause]
if you're a pet parent like me and a lot
of you guys are
that's right
makes me so happy there's so many of us
here in this room and for those who are
watching you know what a challenge it
can be to keep your furry friends fresh
and clean
no joke and that's why i was so excited
to team up with petsmart and introduce
my dogs douglas and lucy to their top
groomers take a look
hi guys how are you good how are you so
nice to meet you guys we are so excited
to meet lucy and douglas today this is
lucy and that's douglas and they're very
much in love they've been together
almost nine years now oh
best friends too you can tell
yeah they're very different dogs they
have very different coats lucy's hair
it's so grody from the new york city
streets what is your advice
on how often
i should groom lucy i would recommend
probably every four to six weeks for
more of a ferminator treatment because
you want to get that undercoat out
because she looks like she sheds a lot
but it's more than just the firminator
it's really the whole process the brush
specialized shampoo conditioner and a
blowout so really get that undercoat out
because that's also what's going to
attract a lot of that dirt so i brought
the ferminator with me and so do you
want me to show you how to use it i mean
i have four cats two dogs six chickens a
bearded dragon oh and a fish named
blueberry
um my house is kind of covered in animal
hair so this is a solution
yes definitely because i'm sure you
probably can't wear black pants a lot oh
i mean if i was a human lint roller that
would that would happen
what you do is you just go along the
growth
and not a lot of pressure
but see all that hair coming out
that's what three strokes okay and in a
salon like ashley said they'll get the
full treatment so it's the shampoo the
conditioner
frying as well as the brushes you could
go to the salon
what does it take to become a groomer at
a petsmart oh gosh it's such a
commitment most all of our styles start
out as a bather and they work their way
up through our training program over 800
hours
of classroom time with hands-on training
to learn all different types of dogs
breed knowledge and you have to be so
passionate about animals to do what we
do because you take all kinds and we
don't just groom dogs in our salons we
also groom cats and felines what about
bearded dragons because jeremy if you
think i've got dry legs you should meet
jeremy we don't do bearded dragon
grooming yet but maybe in the future
i never know i love that it takes that
long to train
to become a groomer so that the customer
and the owner
feels so safe i mean we've been with
petsmart a long time like this is my
20th year with the company and christy
has been with us 14 years now and she's
also our top 10 member for groom team
usa i am
okay then what do you recommend for
douglas i would recommend our hemp's
package which is a really good shampoo
conditioning treatment you want to add
moisture back into that coat i'd also do
nail grinding which helps keep the nails
really nice and short and smooth so if
he jumps up won't scratch the kids or
you know keeps them nice and short
around the house on hardwood floors
this is a dremel but it has a special
head on it for dogs so it doesn't make
the nail warm or hot it's just the
vibration that feels a little funny well
i would like some of that that's really
nice
so now that we've brushed them out and
done some stuff we have our summer
collection of bandanas here would you
like to pick out something for each of
them it's going to be hard to choose
because i'm so into that
i think i'm gonna go for these two
no shocker here i'm gonna go with the
flowers it's my fave and then i'm
definitely going with the popsicle motif
because these are just sparking a lot of
joy
oh that whole segment i was like look at
that dog look at that dog i just want to
give a huge thank you to ashley and
christy from petsmart for showing me all
the amazing services they offer and if
you want to pamper your furry friends
head over to petsmart.com
to book a grooming or just a walk-in for
a stand-alone service and we want our
studio audience to get in on all the fun
so you're all going home with a hundred
dollar gift card
[Music]